you could you're a generation older but  I asked my mom I'm like do the hoes get  married too she said yeah so at the end  of the day there's really not a lot of  consequences for any of it see I think  they have to have bought the story to an  extent because there's too many of them  that aren't comfortable being  promiscuous like they'll do it but they  go home they're miserable they cry about  it they call their friends they're mad  yeah they're mad the guy didn't call  them back they're expecting that guy to  behave like a boyfriend when it was  really clearly just to hook up so  they're so upset about it that they're  then trying to map out with their friend  on the phone like why doesn't he like me  because it's like they bought the story  that somehow they were going to be  promiscuous and it was going to feel  good and they were going to get what  they wanted or something beneficial for  them out of that situation